salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
vous connaissez tous le célèbre pharaon
toutankham mais ce que vous ne savez
peut-être pas c'est que peu après la
découverte de son tombeau en 1922 il y a
pile un siècle une terrible malédiction
ce serait abattu sur tous ceux qui ont
fouillé sa sépulture avec Thibault de la
chaîne Histoire appliquée nous allons
faire toute la lumière sur cette énigme
l'une des plus fascinantes du 20e siècle
[Musique]
le 4 novembre 1922 sous le soleil brûle
en Égypte un jeune porteur d'eau
découvre une marche dans le sable qui
semble s'enfoncer dans le sol il est
loin d'imaginer qu'elle va mener un
groupe d'archéologues britannique vers
le tombeau de Toutankhamon l’une des
découvertes archéologiques les plus
célèbres de tous les temps mais qui
était Toutankhamon
né vers 1345 avant notre ère il est le
fils d'Akhenaton l'un des plus célèbres
pharaons de la civilisation égyptienne
mais aussi l'un des plus controversées
grand réformateur il s'est mis à dos les
responsables religieux de son époque et
a laissé un bilan économique et
politique absolument désastreux son fils
le jeune Toutankhamon n'a que 9 ans
lorsqu'il monte sur le trône après la
mort de son père probablement entouré de
bons conseillers il abandonne certaines
réformes de son père et tentent de
revenir à des approches plus
traditionnelles du pouvoir mais en
dehors de cela on sait assez peu de
choses de son action politique car il
est mort prématurément à l'âge de 18 ou
19 ans les écrits de l'époque ne
précisent pas les causes de sa mort une
hypothèse a longtemps prévalu celle de
l'assassinat mais elle est
définitivement abandonnée en 2005 on a
aussi avancé la thèse d'une mort
accidentelle le mauvais état de son
squelette suggère qu'il aurait pu
succomber à un accident de char une
charge d'hippopotame et là encore rien
n'est moins sûr car ces blessures
semblent avoir été faites après sa mort
pendant la manipulation de la momie pour
l'heure l'hypothèse de la déjà dit reste
la plus plausible on sait que
Toutankhamon était de constitution
fragile une fracture à la jambe a pu
s'infecter et provoquer son décès dans
dafroses souffrances conséquence
inattendue les égyptiens n'ont pas eu le
temps de lui édifier une tombe
monumentale tout en Camon est enterré
dans un tombeau très simple et très
discret c'est ce qui explique sans doute
qu'il est échappé au regard des pilleurs
de tombes durant des millénaires et
qu'il est bien failli échapper aussi au
regard des archéologues du 20e siècle en
effet sans la ténacité d'un archéologue
britannique nommé Howard Carter nous
serions peut-être passer à côté d'une
découverte fabuleuse
de cette découverte débute à l'aube des
années 1910 dans la Vallée des Rois
nichés en plein désert égyptien cette
zone ensablée abrite de nombreuses
tombes elle est donc l'objet de toutes
les convoitises depuis 10 ans on y a
découvert une trentaine de tombeau plus
ou moins intéressant leur carnaval un
aristocrate anglais passionné
d’egyptologie rachète les droits de
fouilles en 1915 à ce moment-là la
plupart des archéologues pensent que la
Vallée des Rois n'a plus aucun secret à
livrer seul un homme et personnel du
contraire c'est l'egyptologue
britannique Howard Carter en 1917 il
convainquar narvan de continuer à
financer les fouilles il a beau chercher
lui non plus ne trouve rien jusqu'à
l'automne 1922 ou quelque chose
d'incroyable se produit il s'agit de la
découverte par hasard d'une marche en
pierre par le jeune porteur d'eau dont
je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure
l'archéologue comprend qu'elle mène
probablement vers un tombeau bien caché
il décide alors d'en dégager l'accès
comme beaucoup d'autres cette tombe a
probablement était vidée de son contenu
Carter ne se fait donc aucune illusion
sur ce qu'il va trouver à l'intérieur
rien ou presque mais il n'abandonne pas
il tombe finalement sur une porte dont
les sauts sont restés intactes
l’égyptologue comprend alors qu'il est
devant le tombeau de Toutankhamon il
n'en revient pas enfin le 26 novembre
1922 il réussit à introduire une bougie
dans la tombe par une brèche ouverte
dans une deuxième porte encore scellée
il parvient alors à apercevoir ce qui se
cache à l'intérieur de l'antichambre et
ce qui y voit le laisse sans voix durant
de longues secondes à l'extérieur lors
carnaval s'impatiente Howard que
voyez-vous en réponse l’égyptologue lui
lance alors cette réplique qui est
entrée dans l'histoire je vois des
choses merveilleuses il vient de
découvrir le trésor de Toutankhamon dans
la liste détaillée des merveilles qu'il
contient pourrait faire l'objet d'une
vidéo entière dans ce trésor et
gigantesque Carter écrira plus tard
c'était un vrai musée une pièce meublée
des objets les plus divers les uns
familiers d'autres que l'on n'avait
jamais vu entasser les uns sur les
autres dans une profusion infinie il lui
faudra environ 10 ans avec son équipe
pour en dresser l'inventaire complet
on va quand même vous en donner un
aperçu en tout on recense près de 5400
objets dans le tombeau du jeune pharaon
ça va du matériel d'écriture aux armes
en passant par des meubles des statuts
des bijoux des pierres précieuses des
objets de la vie courante et pas moins
de 6 chars on y découvre également un
trône incrusté d'or et 134 de marche les
cannes c'est un symbole bien connu des
pharaons mais leur nombre
particulièrement élevés ici pour être
accréditer l’hypothèse d'un jeune homme
qui avait de grandes difficultés à
marcher les pièces les plus
emblématiques de ce trésor ce sont bien
entendu les trois sarcophages en forme
de momie qui abrite la dépouille de
Toutankhamon ainsi que son fameux masque
funéraire recouvert de plaques d'or des
plaques pas des feuilles il donne une
idée du talon des artisans de l'époque
alors évidemment c'est incroyable
découverte stupéfit le monde entier mais
très vite l'histoire va prendre une
drôle de tournure certains vont affirmer
preuve à l'appui que le tombeau de
Toutankhamon est maudit
en 1923 6 semaines après la découverte
lorsqu’arrone meurt brusquement d'une
infection généralisée son décès intrigue
certains journalistes qui échafaudent
alors une incroyable hypothèse tout en
Camon aurait jeté un sort à ceux qui ont
osé troubler son repos éternel pour
preuve il publie le texte d'une mise en
garde soi-disant inscrite à l'entrée du
tombeau la mort vient ailer à quiconque
pénètre dans la tombe d'un pharaon nous
sommes dans une époque où on se
passionne pour le spiritisme et les
sciences occultes beaucoup de gens
croient dur comme faire que les momies
ont des pouvoirs magiques cette
malédiction est donc prise très au
sérieux d'autant qu'au mois de mai
suivant on apprend le décès du
professeur Lafleur un égyptologue
canadien puis la mort du colonel Aubrais
herberthe le propre frère de Carnavon
entre 1923 et 1930 on recense la mort
suspecte de 15 à 30 personnes ayant eu
un lien direct ou indirect avec la
découverte de la momie Toutankhamon
quelques scientifiques échafaudent alors
des théories sur les causes de ces décès
les torches du tombeau aurait été
imprégnées d'arsenic l'huile d'amande
douce utilisée pour embaumer la momie ce
serait transformé en cyanure bref ce
macabre bilan alimente toutes les
conversations dans la rue dans les
salons partout on va jusqu'à consulter
des experts autoproclamés comme Conan
Doyle le créateur de Sherlock Holmes
afin qu'il donne leur avis sur la
question mais cette affaire de
malédiction est loin de convaincre tout
le monde quelques journalistes un peu
sérieux décident de mener l'enquête et
ils n'ont aucune difficulté à démontrer
que cette histoire ne tient absolument
pas debout
[Musique]
a commencé par la mort de lorsqu'un
Narbonne elle n'a rien de suspect de
santé fragile l'aristocrate a succombé à
une septicémie provoquée par une simple
piqûre d'insecte en outre on découvre
que la plupart des victimes n'étaient
même pas présentes lors de la découverte
du tombeau à contrario d'autres
personnes présentes sur les lieux
mourront bien plus tard au warcarter
rend lame 17 ans après la découverte en
1939 et la propre fille du Lord présente
elle aussi disparaît en 1980 à l'âge de
79 ans si on ajoute que la moyenne d'âge
des défunts était d'environ 52 ans ce
qui correspond à peu près à l'espérance
de vie dans les années 20 le doute n'est
plus permis la thèse de la malédiction
est une pure mascarade ah j'allais
oublier la cerise sur le gâteau vous
vous souvenez de la fameuse inscription
à l'entrée de la tombe la mort vient
ailer à quicon pénètre dans l'attente
d'un pharaon tout ça et bien en réalité
on apprendra qu'elle n'a jamais existé
c'est une pure invention des
journalistes ils ont monté cette
histoire de toutes pièces à l'origine
pour se venger de Carter et carnavun qui
avait l'exclusivité au Times de Londres
pour la couverture médiatique de la
fouille du tombeau privée d'informations
ils ont trouvé un bon moyen d'alimenter
leurs colonnes à bon compte par la suite
la question de la vengeance ne se pose
plus du tout mais l'histoire était si
bonne qu'ils en ont fait un feuilleton
qui a évolué de semaine en semaine pour
le plus grand bonheur des lecteurs
on l'a bien compris
est une pure invention mais ce qui est
Caucase c'est que cette malédiction va
tout de même faire beaucoup de reux
avez-vous déjà entendu parler de la
bénédiction du pharaon il s'agit d'une
expression utilisée par l'égyptologue
français Marc gabold l'un des plus
grands spécialistes contemporains de
l'Égypte antique il affirme que la peur
d'une malédiction à cette époque a
poussé de nombreux propriétaires
d'oeuvres égyptiennes à s'en séparer ces
gens étaient persuadés que ces objets
allaient leur porter malheur résultat
les musées ont pu récupérer à peu de
frais et énormément de pièces
historiques de valeur on les trouve
encore aujourd'hui dans leur collection
et contrairement à la malédiction du
pharaon cette bénédiction elle est bien
réelle aujourd'hui encore les
expositions consacrées au trésor de
Toutankhamon attirent des centaines de
milliers de visiteurs c'est là toute
l’ironie de l'histoire Toutankhamon a eu
un règne particulièrement court et
insignifiant pourtant il est devenu
grâce à l'archéologie et au phénomène de
société de l’égyptomanie des pharaons
les plus célèbres de l'histoire reste
que l’égypte et sa civilisation antique
passionne encore et que les bonnes
histoires de Pharaon maudit ont de beaux
jours devant elle merci Thibault pour
cette histoire
épicurieuse et un grand merci aussi à
Toutankhamon pour les merveilles qu'il
nous a laissés si vous avez aimé cette
vidéo vous connaissez la consigne vous
laissez un pouce bleu et vous vous
abonnez si ce n'est pas déjà fait enfin
si vous avez des idées de sujets ne vous
gênez surtout pas proposez-les elles
seront étudiées minutieusement allez à
très bientôt chers épicurieuses et
épicurieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]